yeah it was a surprise to me the gay
response was surprising to me because I
have this fantasy or this idea that gay
men because they share the same sex
drive or similar you know I mean they're
more alike in their sexuality than a man
and a woman that they would sort of both
sign off on having open relationships
and in fact gay men in this country tend
to the in their partnerships tend to
emulate straight partnerships and one
friend said you know the minute someone
says we're in an open marriage now or
open partnership you know he says I look
at my watch to see how long the
relationships going to last so that's
not that different from straight people
but I'm told that in Europe you know the
the gay guys have a much more open
understanding but that's like I think
that's a little like the straight people
in Europe too but I'm surprised by that